Tom we can barely keep up with you
you've done so much since Harry Potter
tell us a little bit about it you've got
fangs of war
you've got Tories reckon with Elizabeth
Olsen brilliant
you've also got labyrinth coming up TV
as well at loads more besides give us a
little bit insight
well yeah they're all worlds apart from
each other but all very exciting
characters and stories I'm not sure
what's going to come out first to be
honest with you out of the three or four
things that are still yet to come out
but the period piece is a great fun
Terez was a lot of fun it's a great
story and I got to play a very unique
character and and very contrasting in in
labyrinth which is said in the sort of
13th century or 12th century rather
southern France gets sort of beer a vie
count which is like a prince which was a
lot of fun as well yeah chainmail and
slaying people which is always good fun
right there's lots of films that I'm
hoping and as far as I know I'm looking
to go ahead early next year but I
haven't heard any imminent start dates
and that's just one of the ones that I'm
hoping is gonna start early next year
it's kind of Dracula esque isn't it you
have found of those kind of Bram Stoker
I am annoying I am and I'm not it's a
weird one I find that if it manages to
suck me in it and it's a very believable
story then immediately I can enjoy it to
be honest with you friends of war was
one that I would instantly usually think
this is not for me but upon reading it
actually had quite a quite an enticing
read yeah yeah and made a lot of middle
of a sense so yeah I can mean I can
enjoy it if it's quite close to home
definitely
you